hey this is press tow Walker the diagram
shows a sphere with Center o that
contains a cone whose diameter AB is
equal to its height
CM what is the ratio of the cone's
volume to the sphere's
volume this was posted on Reddit askmath
with the title that nobody at the person
school could solve the
problem pause the video if you'd like to
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching to learn how to
solve this
[Music]
problem let's work it out step by step
the volume of a cone is equal to PK r^ 2
H all over 3 suppose a sphere has a
different radius capital r the volume of
the sphere is equal to 4 Pi capital R
cubed all over
3 so we ideally want to get the radius
and the height of the cone in terms of
the radius of the sphere so we'd want R
to be equal to some constant time the
radius of the sphere and H to also be
equal to some constant times the radius
of the sphere so let's see how we can
work this out to begin let capital r be
the radius of the sphere so OC is equal
to R and O A is also equal to R let om M
be equal to some distance
d
now cm is equal to r + D and we know
that AB is equal to CM that's given
information so a is equal to half of ab
and that is equal to r + D all over 2 so
a = MB = r + D all over 2 let's now
focus on triangle a o since it's a right
triangle a^ 2 + o^ 2 is equal to AO 2 so
so we substitute in for a o m and
AO let's now focus on just this
equation we will Square the
binomial then we will multiply both
sides by
four we can then group like terms so we
end up with 5D ^2 + 2 Rd - 3 r^ 2 is
equal to
Z we'll solve this equation for
D we can try to factor so we have 5D ^2
and -3 R 2 so it could be factored as 5D
minus something multiplied 3 R plus
something so in order to force 5D ^ 2
and to get 3 r^ 2 we would need to have
5D - R multiplied 3 r + D but if we
expand this out this will be 5D ^2 +
14dr - 3 r^ 2 and this is not what the
original quadratic was so this is not
what it factors into so instead we could
try 5D minus something * r +
something so this must be 5D minus 3r *
r + D expanding this out this does
exactly match the original equation so
this is what it factors
into so now we have two possible
solutions we have D is equal to 3 R 5 or
D is equal to R but we want D to be some
positive value so we'll eliminate that D
is equal to R so D is equal to 3 R over
5 from here cm is equal to r + D and
that will be 8 R over 5 then a is equal
to half of that so that'll be equal to 4
R over
5 we've now solved for the height and
the radius of the cone so the volume of
the cone is equal to Pi multipli by a^ 2
* CM all over three so we can substitute
in and then we just need to simplify so
that we get the volume of the cone is
equal to 128 piun R Cub all over 3 *
125 finally we have the volume of the
sphere is equal to 4 pi r Cub all over 3
so we take the volume of the cone
divided by the volume of the sphere the
pi r Cub terms cancel out the threes and
the denominators cancel out out so this
is equal to 128 / 125 all over 4 and
that simplifies to be 32 / 125 which
equals
256 and that's the
answer thanks for making us one of the
best communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
time
oh